Hey youtubers, it's Charlie! This is going
to be my Gotham Episode 10 video. One more
episode left in the first half of the season.
So let's go! Just careful for spoilers if
you haven't seen the episode yet as he gets
it like the biggest thing in the episode I
think is Bruce Wayne going a little Batman
just one step closer to being the world's
greatest detective just to start with top
five WTF Bruce versus Silver so we we finally
get to see Bruce take her on and we learned
that he was deceiving her at least a little
bit this entire type this episode he really
laid it on thick when they show that creepy
rape fan checking them out I totally took
the bait who else thought the minute they
open that fan and silver was tied up the you
thought that she was the one that hired them
it made the Bruce revealed the end that much
more fun if you guys are familiar M Malone
the character that silver names is matches
Malone from the comics know what they've done
is they've twisted because Joe chill is the
person who killed Batman's parents I'm not
sure why they're using matches Malone in this
way because matches Malone is the secret name
that Bruce Wayne uses when he wants to infiltrate
criminal organizations to give you ever seen
Batman the animated series there a couple
episodes where he actually puts a fake makeup
on what he pretends to be someone else to
get information matches Malone blows a lot
from the world's greatest detective stuff
and it is fun seeing Bruce and Catwoman work
together again those two actors I feel like
work best when they're together on screen
with you love or hate child actors I feel
like their scenes work best when they're playing
off of other child actors when they are doing
kid stuff on my number four WTF Gordon Bullock
played a in the sewers so this is so fun seeing
them together again there's been a criminal
lack of Gordon Bullock scenes the first half
of the season I think we'll get more that
now the book is back on the force the whole
deal with the first part of the season was
Bullock being like I'm done with this I'm
not can be cop anymore but it did last just
a little bit when Gordon went all Batman voice
to try get information out of the order he
learned the order is trying to kill the son
of Gotham but he doesn't know the Bruce is
the son of Gotham yet it gives you a good
idea for how the people in the city think
of Bruce right now when you read stories about
adult Bruce Wayne in his own comic books the
city thinks of him as being a very big deal
is the most powerful most influential character
inside Gotham city so of course everybody
that lives in the city thinks of him as the
son of Gotham double-edged sword is that Batman
is also the son of Gotham all the terrible
things in Gotham got together had a baby and
that baby's Batman on my number three WTF
Theo's evil villain model logging is is is
you kind of a funny thing for anyone that
is watch the incredible's because you know
it's like the worst thing ever for a villain
to be cop model logging oh my God you commie
model logging this is a really important scene
but I feel like the way they set it up was
complete ham sandwich with the best comic
book moments on TV turned the lesser moments
into the ham sandwich you know like like Barry
Allen going on a date being awkward that's
complete ham sandwich is not really that important
the moment when your big bad makes a big reveal
you really you don't want to be too awkward
and I feel like this deal Gotham reveal was
way too deliberate for whatever we learned
a couple important things Theo is a really
bad ass fighter and he has everyone on their
knees right now or lease he thinks he does
he had Gordon captive until pain one rescued
him and now he has Bruce with his family's
knife so he's going to exact his revenge on
my number two WTF the Penguin in the Riddler
continue their strange relationship the whole
comedy that situation was Lee walking up and
saying hey has it going you know what's what's
going on with Ms. Kringle oh she's gone she
she took off with her abuser never you mind
that ringing phone in and actually the interesting
thing is is that he save Ms. Kringle's glasses
despite the big speech that he gave the Penguin
last week this is a very Batman villain type
of thing sabotaging your own evil plans because
of the little bit of human that left inside
of you even though usually you see villains
exploiting heroes weaknesses to get what they
want them it does the exact same thing he
will not hesitate to exploit the humanity
in villains to take them down the thing about
villains this season on Gotham though is that
I think Theo doesn't really have any humanity
he has his sister I haven't really gotten
a family buy from them it seems like Tabitha
cares more about the open Theo cares about
Tabitha speed which on my number one WTF moment
Alfred versus tabby I totally love the color
tabby this is the best fighter the episode
this version of Alfred way better than the
movie versions of Alfred is a whole lot of
things on Gotham this season that I feel like
her a lot better than they were in season
one the show itself is getting a lot better
season to season episode to episode but consistently
this version of Alfred has always been awesome
Sean perch was Alfred one of the best I know
people got really upset when he slapped Catwoman
earlier this season but this version of Alfred's
hard-core this is hard-core Alfred Hislop
anybody he wants the bigger question I saw
people asking about Tabitha though is whether
or not calamine is going to get her with at
some point because the whip is a big part
of the tab of the character so hopefully will
at least see Selena acknowledging the whip
is being really cool like all man I had to
try that sometime but just in general something
tells me that Selena's progress towards becoming
the Catwoman character will mirror Bruce's
journey to becoming the Batman characters
so they'll bill proceeded about the same pace
so don't expect one to get a costume before
the other but let me know in the comments
below what is your favorite moment from the
episode and what you think is going to happen
with the order St. Dumas after the midseason
finale Judy to get a push in the back half
of the season because they still have their
court of owls storyline to surface the can't
really get through that to we do order St.
Dumas stuff and they haven't even brought
as rel on the show yet it is a younger version
of the character would appear at some point
but because the order of St. Dumas such a
big family is like a league of assassins situation
where I don't think they'll ever completely
go away forever. Ryan up doing is dealing
with this blood of the nine situations save
Bruce Wayne in the order of St. Dumas will
flow into a court of owls storyline because
I think this blood of the nine has to do with
the original ruling families of Gotham although
primarily their beef is with the Wayne family
but I do think Gotham totally made the right
move and giving Bruce kind of this mystery
arc about his origins his family's origins
like all we come from the secret society that
did terrible things what's learn more about
this so regardless of any ham sandwiches that
you want to hold against the show I feel like
it's moving in the right direction but just
to give you guys an update on what's going
on this week the schedules a little bit different
because it's Thanksgiving week in the United
States so couple shows romp break there is
an episode of Supergirl do a video for that
later I also got some really cool stuff from
the Shinar people at MTV's I'll do a video
for that later this week to and they're supposed
to be Captain America Civil War footage tonight
so that ends up happening I will totally do
a video for that next is I have until much
much later tonight just in case you guys haven't
seen it so much game of thrones in legends
of tomorrow stuff happen yesterday you can
click here for the full legends of tomorrow
trailer footage from the actual series is
so bad ass and you can click here to learn
all about the Jon Snow game of thrones teaser
the HBO posted think you so much for watching,
everybody let's high five and I'll see you
guys tonight!